[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
die pro tritt kamen im soester vor bei
euch an dass ich gedacht habe machen wir
heute doch noch ein produkt viele von
euch haben sich einen weizen mischbrot
gewünscht deswegen haben wir hier 1 und
zwar besteht zu 80 prozent aus weizen
und zu 20 prozent aus dinkel und auch
hier habe ich wieder das korn selber
gemahlen und natürlich auch die
selbstgemachte hefe benutzt also dass
hefe wasser und da findet ihr das rezept
auf meinem kanal und es sieht echt super
aus vor allem ist super einfach man muss
gar nicht lange kneten
es wird ja am tag vorher schon der teig
zubereitet das heißt ich setze den
sauerteig und den vorteil kann und am
ende muss ich nur noch alles gut
verbinden und dann zeige ich euch noch
die technik wie man das brot hier eben
ein schneidet das ist eben auch so
hübsch aussieht und ich finde es richtig
schön
wir sind gerade am anfang des videos
morath höchsten das programmende
anschneiden auch sowie das heißt wir
gehen jetzt erst einmal einen tag zurück
wenn ich zeig euch jetzt was ihr für
zutaten benötigt und wie man den teig
macht den sauerteig brauche ich 108
gramm dinkel körner und 108 gramm hefe
wasser und für den vortrag brauche ich 4
134 gramm weizenkörner 314 gramm wasser
und zwölf gramm salz zuerst werden jetzt
die körner gemahlen und dieses mal habe
ich jetzt die getreidemühle einfach auf
den mini drauf gesetzt denn die mini
hatte wirklich auch einfach genauso viel
power wie die große maschine
das heißt hier funktioniert es auch
prima
natürlich mit etwas strom handkurbel
wenn nämlich nicht ganz so gut dann
brauchen wir keine küchenmaschinen
[Musik]
bei der mini hat man auch wenn die
körner fertig sind
da gibt es einfach keine reibung das
jetzt ausschütteln dann die schüssel
darunter weg und jetzt nämlich direkt
ein schraubglas und einem richter dennis
wacker mit sicherheit wenn nicht ich wer
dann
da kommt das mädel rein ich glaube ich
muss auch an dieser stelle wieder sagen
selbst gemahlenes mehl ist wirklich viel
besser als gekauft das sind rund um den
sauerteig herzustellen kommt jetzt hier
noch das hefe wasser mit rein und damit
alles verrührt
jetzt luftdicht verschließen unterstelle
jetzt kurz zur seite und bleibt noch die
übrigen körner malen
[Musik]
das habe ich auch hier das mehl für den
vorteig und hier kommt noch das wasser
mit dazu und das salz und auch die
zutaten werden jetzt gut vermischt
entweder nimmt jetzt den teig schaber
wurde einfach die hände
[Musik]
und jetzt fühle ich den vortrag auch in
den staub gefäß und verschließe und da
kann ich es über nacht stehen lassen und
das dauert es etwa zwölf bis 15 stunden
einfach bei raumtemperatur lagern und
dann kann ich morgen nämlich das leckere
brot backen
nach der uhrzeit seht der weizen teig
jetzt so aus habe ich den sauerteig und
hier im vorteil
und jetzt kann ich beide teile
miteinander verbinden damit praktisch
ohne super hübsche geschenke vorteig und
sache direkt zu verschenken
nur mist mache eine zeitliche anleitung
natürlich mit reinschreiben
ich glaube wenn der murat mir so was
schenken würde weil ich nicht ganz so
begeistert weil immerhin würde mich dann
in die küche finden also schwierig nicht
ganz und vorteil wenn ihr männer das
eurer frau schenkt andersrum gestellt
was anderes dann darf der mann mal das
brotbacken steht emma in der küche
[Musik]
so und jetzt werden beide teile
miteinander verbunden
und dann habe ich hier vorne noch 25
gramm olivenöl und sobald die tage
verbunden sind kommt noch das 4 1
ich habe jetzt hier eine eckige schüssel
da weil ich den tag jetzt gleich noch
mal rein geben denn wir müssen den teig
jetzt nochmals tratschen und faltenlos
träsch und jetzt nämlich denn hier rein
und zwar bekommt dadurch eine schöne
oberfläche er wird einfach formstabil
und wir schließen natürlich ein bisschen
luft mit ein
eckig ist ganz gut denn dann weiß ich
einfach welche seite ich schon gefaltet
habe es macht mir ist das ganz das ganze
ein bisschen einfacher jetzt nehmt ihr
den teig von außen und faltet dem dann
die gegenüberliegende seite ziehen bis
zum widerstand den teig nicht verreisen
und am besten die hände immer ein
bisschen angst machen und die vierte
seite ziehen und falten
und jetzt kommt der tag mit der naht
nach unten und jetzt werde ich den teig
abdecken ihnen für eine stunde der
raumtemperatur aufgehen lassen und das
ganze wird er noch zweimal wiederholt
jetzt habe ich eine stunde gewartet
jetzt kann ich den teig wieder falten
lassen dann auch wieder eine stunde
aufgehen und macht das ganze dann noch
einmal also ab jetzt noch zwei mal
falsch
[Musik]
nicht vergessen vorher umzudrehen sagte
jetzt wieder abdecken und eine stunde
ruhen lassen
das war die letzte faltung also die
dritte und jetzt werde ich den tag noch
einmal abdecken für eine stunde ruhen
lassen und dann können wir das brot form
jetzt ist der teig bereit und ich habe
jetzt hier bereits die arbeitsfläche mit
mehl bestreut gebe ich da den teig drauf
und damit ich jetzt eine schöne
oberfläche bekomme und spannung darauf
bekomme muss ich den teigen wir sind
falten und ich werde es im teig gleich
hinauf gehen lassen und ihnen geld
kommen und jetzt macht ihr das ganze so
immer über die diagonale so sehen also
dass er nicht reist und dadurch dass ich
jetzt eine oberflächenspannung bekomme
treten die gase nicht aus und so bekommt
das brot einfach eine schönere form und
mehr volumen und dann wenn ihr merkt ihr
könnt jetzt nicht mehr falten und ziehen
ihr merkt es einfach es fängt dann an zu
reißen aber kurz vorher solltet ihr
aufhören und dann könnt ihr hier oben so
eine naht machen sowie zusammengehen
sozusagen
[Musik]
und jetzt werde ich auch gleich mit dem
nach oben ins körbchen legen aber damit
der teig da jetzt nicht drin hängen
bleibt muss ich das bestreuen nicht mit
normalem mehl sondern nicht mehr mit
gluten freies mail das heißt ich habe
hier reis mit vorbereitet das ganze habe
ich auch mit der getreidemühle
hergestellt ist auch wirklich super
einfach glutenfrei deswegen damit sich
datei gibt es nicht mit dem geld ob
verbindet und jetzt am besten mit der
naht nach oben
denn ich drehe das brot später um
jetzt werde ich das gut abdecken
und wenn es noch mal für eine stunde bis
eineinhalb stunden aufgehen lassen ist
das weiß nur sport sorgt jetzt kommt es
gleich in den backofen so sieht momentan
aus und ich werde jetzt gleich aus der
form heraus stürzen
das heißt ich habe hier schon mal in
einem backofen einen gusseisernen topf
einen länglichen und damit dieses gleich
rein bekomme ohne mich zu verbrennen
nämlich ein backpapier und zwar wollte
ich das so und jetzt habe ich hier die
geschlossene seite wird die offene und
jetzt kann ich es hier mit hinlegen und
werde zum rechteck rausschneiden so dass
später einfach ein kreuz entsteht und so
kann ich einfach sichergehen dass nicht
so viele falten entstehen wenn ich das
backpapier reinlegen
und das ist kein zufall so sieht es
jetzt aus das brot passt jetzt perfekt
drauf zum stürzen nehme ich jetzt einen
tacken retter und kampf darauf stützen
[Musik]
und damit jetzt beim backen keine risse
entstehen denn das würde nämlich
passieren denn ich habe jetzt im teig
nicht gebundenes wasser das heißt das
wasser sorgt dafür dass die poren
gebunden werden und das wasser kocht
jetzt im brot steigt nach oben und dann
würde eben das boot reisen damit das
nicht passiert werde ich jetzt einen
scharfes messer nehmen ihr könnt auch
eine rasierklinge zum beispiel nehmen
und könnte das brot einschneiden
befeuchtet allerdings mache nehme ich
jetzt als überschüssige mehr weg
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich das messer und mache
jetzt einfach kurze aber auch tiefe
schnitte hier einmal in der mitte und
dann auch hier außen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der weg frei für die gase
jetzt hole ich den gusseisernen topf
heraus vorsichtig den deckel weg und
jetzt kann ich mithilfe des papiers das
brot schön reinlegen
ganz vorsichtig und die falten die sich
jetzt gebildet haben
streiche ich jetzt schon sagt damit das
brot auch eine schöne form bekommt jetzt
kommt der deckel wieder drauf weder mit
dem handschuh und dann kommt das brot in
den vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 40
grad für etwa 40 minuten und ich erzähle
euch jetzt warum ich das brot in
gusseisen und zwar ist es so dass man
das brot mit schwarzen balken kann das
heißt mit einem wasserdampf stoß viele
begriffen haben dass auch und ich könnte
es hier bei dem sogar auch machen aber
ich wollte euch natürlich die methode
zeigen wir das ganz einfach zu hause
nachmachen können und zwar steigt ihr
jetzt der wasserdampf hoch und durch den
deckel durch den gusseisernen topf wird
es einfach wieder gefangen geht wieder
zum brot zurück und so haben wir später
eine richtig tolle kruste so 20 minuten
backen dann den deckel entfernen und
noch einmal weitere 15 bis 20 minuten
jetzt ist es soweit der decke kam runter
jetzt beim aufmachen vom topfdeckel
bitte aufpassen denn da steigt jetzt
wasserdampf hervor dass ihr euch nicht
verbrennt ich hab nicht nämlich beim
letzten mal verbrannt jetzt aufpassen
so war das sieht doch mal gut aus das
ist doch mal ein schönes foto
aber ihr seht die farbe ist noch sein
deswegen wird es jetzt ohne deckel noch
mal für weitere 20 minuten gebacken
ach ist das schön das produziert fertig
zum abkühlen hatte ich es gerade eben
noch auf dem abkühlen gitter und jetzt
kann ich nach dem vollständigen abkühlen
anschneiden
das bleibt für mich du kriegst die
nächste scheibe erstmals ohne probleme
ohne dass richter becker also das brot
kann man mit sich ohne belag essen so
karl ecker und drüber ja das kommt eben
durch das setting und geschmack selbst
gemahlen selbst gemahlenem mehl
ja und jetzt wollten wir mit der tomaten
monat abonnieren
und es ist wirklich kein hexenwerk brot
selber herzustellen
die gut 1000 kühe schon folgt ja wenn es
noch leicht warm wer das porto weil das
jetzt oben da hatten die schalte eine
schöne humor ist jetzt mutter mit bissen
brot
nein ich mutter hat ihr nicht ein
brötchen ja
jetzt höre frischen löffel in die
tomaten monate genauso gut vom randen
marmelade
ich liebe tomaten marmeladen so wartet
jetzt das casting schneide ich mag das
für dich mag tomaten kommunale
wahnsinnig
[Musik]
ja und falls er dieses rezept gerne
nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei aufs erlesenes blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz ausführlich
und ihr habt gesehen das ist wirklich
super einfach und vor allem sehr schön
ich habe es eine botschaft für uns ist
andere werde ich meiner mama geben und
zum aufbewahren einfach das boot
aufstellen auf die schnittfläche dann
trocknet es nämlich nicht aus weil sie
viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss und ich könnte
natürlich auch zwei drei tage in essen
viel länger so gar nicht so lange ich
habe von indisches richtig weiter und
ich würde ja nochmal auch ohne zu warten
auf das kurze was sagst du nein ich sehe
sie es
[Musik]